Now, take the typical comedy,...
...there will probably be some type of misunderstanding.
Again, we know more of what is going on than the characters do.
Picture two characters making a plan for a birthday surprise for their roommate...
...while that roommate overhears the entire conversation from the hallway.
From there, confusion and misunderstanding occur and the tension builds.
But this isn't the same tension as the horror film since it is probably pretty funny...
...as the character try to figure out the who's and the what's.
But it serves as a great example of the tension and suspense of dramatic irony.
This tension or suspense in both genres...
...drives the story and keeps the plot progressing the audience wants.
No, needs to see the tension of the dramatic irony broken...
...either by the scary person jumping out of the shadows...
...or by someone finally revealing someone's true identity...
...and clearing up the confusion.
So when you feel like you are in on a secret that is dramatic irony.
A hallmark of all the great writers from Shakespeare to Hitchcock.